aunque se esperaba que el anuncio formal
lo hiciera Noruega país mediador entre
la oposición venezolana y el gobierno de
Nicolás maduro fue el presidente de
Colombia Gustavo Petro quien anunció a
través de sus redes sociales que este 25
y 26 de noviembre se retomaba la mesa de
negociaciones en México entre los temas
a discutir estaría un acuerdo social con
un fondo humanitario para Venezuela
valorado en unos 3.000 millones de
dólares que sería administrado por la
organización de Naciones Unidas las
condiciones para unas eventuales
elecciones presidenciales y la situación
de los presos políticos la principal la
exigencia del gobierno de Nicolás maduro
sigue siendo el levantamiento de las
sanciones que pesan sobre empresas y
funcionarios de la administración de
Nicolás maduro trascendió además según
la agencia routers que en los próximos
días Estados Unidos estaría por anunciar
la ampliación de la licencia que tiene
la estadounidense Chevron para operar en
Venezuela pero que se estaría esperando
precisamente la reanudación del diálogo
entre las partes para hacer este anuncio
recordemos que las conversaciones entre
la oposición venezolana y el gobierno de
Nicolás maduro Fueron suspendidas por el
gobierno de maduro en octubre del año
pasado tras la extradición del
empresario colombiano Alexa acusado por
Estados Unidos de lavado activos pero
que a juicio del gobierno de maduro se
trata de un diplomático venezolano
secuestrado por el gobierno
estadounidense al momento ninguna de las
partes ni oposición y gobierno se han
pronunciado sobre la reanudación de
estas conversaciones en México